so shout out to irene as well my
opponent who's trying to break
a thousand followers on twitch i think
she's really close actually
let's see oh wow
so i'm not intending to stream snipe but
this is uh this is irene's follower
account
so if you want to be among her top
thousand followers
i guess it's not too late just yet
okay let me hide irene's stream so i'm
not actually sniping
complicated position okay i'm gonna
maybe go into a stafford she usually
plays this movement
oh yeah amen tagit thanks brian
okay let's play if i play this she likes
to play bishop b5 so i'll play bishop c5
hey eric what would you say is the best
way for someone to improve at around
1900 elo
oh uh play players you should really
strive to play players
above expert level like when i was 1900
i would play in tournaments uh where i
play upper section so rather than
playing like under 2000
i would play under 2200 um
i know maybe it's different these days
online um
but if you can really try and play
stronger players
you'll you'll begin to see kind of what
it takes to to get to next level
um and yeah at that level
sometimes it can depend more on the
player like it's hard to generalize
of course there's always different areas
to work on
but some players you need to work more
on openings sometimes it's more
exploring ken games a bit more
or just positional play
but usually at that level like there's
clear tendencies or weaknesses to
address
okay so i'm going to avoid castling and
then maybe go for the early
g5 g4 attack
just sometimes what i like to do in
these uh more symmetrical positions
so avoid the symmetry
thank you smashing in gifting to
sibling c c bean hype train
oh yeah so much hype thanks for the high
people
i think it's okay to leave the bishop
here so if we trade then i get a nice
kind of control over the d4 square
and thank you johann mel or your hannah
smell
you sub the tier one and thanks tagi for
the hype train bits
did twitch change their hype train thing
i see like random gifs of things jumping
up and down
i don't know if other people see that
[Music]
whoa it's talking 305 oh thanks so much
followers on youtube
thanks really appreciate that 5000 bits
yeah um it's actually it it got to 351
today
um i think the channel's been averaging
like one to two thousand new subs per
day
um so yeah the growth was pretty crazy
but thanks to everyone who's been so
supportive and subbing
and cheering um
on on twitch but also um i guess you
can't cheer on youtube
but something on youtube okay maybe
how to do this maybe this move
just want to throw as many pieces as
possible
oh yeah we can get some taggy emotes in
the chat
also uh less than an hour ago i broke a
thousand subscribers on youtube
maybe i can show what i mean
um
[Music]
i i have a new youtube channel which i
haven't promoted like so much yet
well it's trying to learn things trying
to learn
gifting gifting so many subs
thanks so much oh trying to learn i saw
your message um
and then i got distracted but uh i'll
reply
um trying to learn has a cool youtube
channel
uh with like mashing up uh chest
commentary
um it might might contribute to some of
my content
but uh okay let's let's focus on the
game
maybe knight f4 i just want to go after
g2
because it's only defender as a king i
can potentially have three attackers
and mikhail balakirev welcome back
gifting gifting five subs
okay am i winning i've been very
unfocused this game but i think i'm
winning
because the g3 the the f1 is pinned i
just take it with something
um i think about irene she
she's a fighter like it's hard to
actually convert winning positions
against her
if it takes it's really close
oh there's a cool idea i think it works
too i
i think i can take look at this idea
please work so takes queen h3 originally
i was about to reject this because queen
f3
but then there's a really cool move rook
g3 and there's a pin like this and
knight's also pinned queen's attacked if
takes takes it's a fork
uh tricky move but just king d8 should
provoke resignation
oh wait a minute i didn't see that move
wait a minute i'm not winning
i thought she was gonna resign
i have to take and then move here
i think it's still winning because she
can't defend the knight
there's this track but then i run and
hide
it's so weird like the pawn's been
pinned for so long
oh i didn't see that
okay i am losing now oh no
oh we have one second increment so i can
live on the increment or die on the
increment
free pawn
i'll play this move okay i think i'm
winning again
wait it's still weird though what is
this game
there we go now i'm winning
but you can never count your chickens
before they hatch okay now i'm
definitely winning
the chickens have hatched okay
well the game i was a little bit
uh distracted that game so much hype in
chat
whoa it's it's gm hikaru subbing for
seven months thank you gm hikaru
also a good game to irene
um i don't know what happened there
what was that this game so this is kind
of the new cool feature on on each say
color code moves
so it's easier to see where the the
moments were
bishop c4 is a blunder bishop c4 is a
blunder because she she didn't accept or
want to go into stafford
uh which she objectively should have
look at this graph a graph it represents
like um
probably some mountain range in iceland
i love fights like that one
nice win eric oh thank you thanks double
pawns
750 bits
yeah so this is like i guess for the
stafford players who
um who maybe get these positions when
like doesn't go into a stafford
uh this is kind of the style of of how i
like to play
like the early push um i'll send another
challenge i guess
wait i'm black again i'm black again
okay i'll mix up the opening we'll play
um i'll play g6
okay let's play let's play this opening
it's called the norwegian rat
um because e59 h5 it looks like
just a terrible opening like black
black moves the same piece twice and
puts the knight on the edge
but in return white's a little bit
overextended now there's a target
i am threatening to take if knight here
there's probably bishop g4
so it's an interesting line also aaron
pilgrim
gifting to cool club zero one thanks
aaron pilgrim
welcome back
now it's a few years ago like magnus was
playing this in a lot of games
before people like fully understood how
to punish it
um there's many cases where
black just allows light to take and win
a pawn
and then in exchange back it's a file
potentially the um
obviously the bishop pair
so in some regard this is kind of a
gambit
yeah sometimes the best way to learn
something
is to just watch how
how uh masters do it
um this doesn't just apply to chess just
any any sort of field
like cooking or any other sport from
italy
thank you for the great content oh thank
you
ciao ciao to italy
i've never been to italy i've never even
tried learning italian
[Music]
i don't think i know too many italian
words apart from
fiance
but italy is high on my bucket list of
of countries to travel to
wow okay irene's being aggressive
f4
interesting move i mean i don't know
what i was thinking about there this is
only safe square okay so now she's
accepting the gambit
which kind of makes me happy
i feel like i'm just more comfortable
being down upon these days
so i could no taking's bad
um this move is met with knight e2
so maybe just knight f6 first if queen
g5 i play rook g8
[Music]
and because
white gave away
the lightsweight bishop uh my lightsword
bishop should be
fun to play with if i can figure out how
to
best approach this position like maybe
this move now
but then queen b5 wait queen b5 takes
takes
this is this
i think it's okay
there's also queen b5 takes takes take
c4 i take on e3
and then the knight gets trapped in the
end and i fork in the end
bishop d4 better move
eight months higher g8s i think it's
very likely my king will
just kind of hide on f8 you see my queen
side castle here
yeah e7 can be a an issue
if i play bishop g4 knight f3
[Music]
let's play a6 first
this is probably not going as i hoped
but there's still some pressure like
bishop five queen c7
will defend and help attack in
conjunction with b5
something to play for
uh she has this move and then queen d7
i think i'm okay i'm very sure that soon
i should play
king f8 also thank you peace links
welcome back and seeing peace links in
irene's chat
and hardly fair new sub
okay so yeah i'm kind of
kind of under pressure
g4 yeah she's threatening to drop my
bishop
play this move this kind of gives white
the g5 square
but it does prevent g4
and white has so much initiative here
okay let's hide the bishop
f5 might be coming the queen is always
tied down to the pawn
i do have this move in brooks c at first
there's a trap if g4 i can take twice
and then queen takes out bishop h6
winning the queen
okay hand waving
hey that may have been just a gambit to
open up more lines
oh hand waving okay uh 95 looks like a
nice move
there's also bishop e5 probably 95.
now i'm blocking e-file so my queen now
has mobility
i need to probably take the pawn
yeah it's such a solid square for the
knight don't hurt me
queen or to move the queen
this square
i'm calculating uh takes takes oh
there's knight g5 man
i was getting so messy
no i flagged ah i could have taken maybe
but the bishop and the queen were
hanging
i was too slow there there's so many
targets in the position
i wonder i'm not seeing any wind
i mean these pieces are are ripe for
attacking but my queen
i'm also being attacked in the final
position yeah white's winning here
whoa accredited lime
credited lime oh like a citrus fruit
good afternoon thank you for the five
dollars
was i losing oh i was better yeah once i
got the knight to e5
oh that was a blunder
oh queen h5 could trap the
bishop rook hate wow
so a combination of queen h5 and 96
that's epic
bishop f6 and then knight e4 look at
this
my king's completely stuck the pawn's
pinned
can i play this move no i can't because
she takes and takes that would have been
so nasty
like why is just squeezing me from all
directions in this line
good game we'll do one more
because i didn't block both games okay
okay final game so the first two games i
was black
i guess this is a tiebreaker uh
what to play
i'll play e4 she's i think she's been
playing e5 more
and now
yeah she might play g6
oh she's playing a petrov
but she she plays normal petrov i've
seen her games
like in in real life um i'm going to
play bishop c4
this is known as the the bowden
kizzaritsky it could go into a stafford
gambit
we'll see how she how prepared she is
i could have maybe considered playing
the caution gambit too
okay so i'll have maybe a staffer gamut
up at tempo
oh hey it's kari shout out to gary
welcome back already your content and
when you sip tea thanks for everything
oh i'll sip more tea just for you thank
you
goodbeen wait is this a move
so i'm gonna be down upon i don't think
i've seen this move before
because people have asked me like what
to do in in this position
and knight d6 is usually not a move i've
ever recommended
but maybe it's playable
castle first and bishop b7 probably
coming
yeah we might get kind of uh one million
twitch subs
one sure why not
i don't think i'll ever hit a million
twitch subscribers
youtube subscribers i think is more
likely
okay i want to play aggressively here
punish this knight for being awkward
not exactly sure how though
this move we trade
promisers might have five in a lot of
lines
so maybe i'll play this move just trying
to win back the pawn
if f6 which probably won't be played
then black has a
hard time castling
okay this reminds me of some
like anti-berlin variation
i kind of want to go crazy here
i mean there's some logic to this move
oh you're so cool too thank you
affiliate streams
i play rook d5 as well
rook t5 is a funny move i think i'll
play rook d5
and just for the lulz because it
prevents knight f5 it also prevents
c6 it's just kind of an awkward square
for the rook
but maybe it'll confuse her
oh b6 i forgot about now i'm tempted to
take
which is not probably a good move
queen g4 maybe
d3 first
okay the rook is popping around g6
expected
i'll probably move back to h3
okay complete development
um i missed rugged seven
unless yeah rook h7 i should have played
because if if king takes i have
horsemate
because here here here
i'm still threatening this so
when she played this i just saw that the
back rank oh
okay it's a welcome surprise
i saw the back ring could be an issue um
so if king takes i check here check king
goes back and then i mate
bishop controls g8 in that line um
she might be most likely to play rook
e1 but then i take and then went f7
so yeah i think she should have played
g6 sooner
probably would have been a better uh
better option
oh okay we're gonna have some fun here
so i don't need to take that bishop oh
wait a minute
i even need to i can start with this
move
puzzle rush or puzzle storm i should say
and then this
is she gonna resign or will she let me
display my work of art
please don't resign please
one legal move okay that's very
courteous
okay so my rook proved to be useful
i didn't say this usually it's something
you shouldn't do with like moving the
rook
so much in the opponent's territory but
yeah the rook
was able to sacrifice itself for a good
cause
okay maybe we'll do one more we'll make
it um
yeah for even four games last game
at least in this series
i've been wanting to mix up the openings
um
i'm running out of fun things to play
maybe i'll play no kelly
oh kelly is usually not the type of
thing you should play against a strong
player though
oh she's playing knight c3 okay so oh
kelly is a6 against knight f3
but a6 against knight c3 is um actually
usually what i play anyway
[Music]
also thank you aspen magic appreciate
the bits and the kind words
and thanks to the fish 27 96
have i seen the jonathan trance new
berlin i have
i've been meaning to look into it it
looks like a really interesting
obviously dubious but really interesting
line
um yeah 93 is probably a good move
please listen to d5 give eric a
compliment alexa
give me a compliment you're so sweet
you're like the corner piece of a
brownie just right
oh thanks for that i don't know if
people heard that it was kind of quiet
but she called me the corner piece of a
brownie
i don't even know what that means
alexa volume seven
alexa give me another compliment
you're so swell when you go for a walk
surfers ride in your wake
that makes me a little bit more
confident i guess
brightens my self-esteem
yeah apologies if it was still too quiet
okay let's uh let's continue developing
to stay focused
i'm going to try and keep my plus score
so generally white plays f4 and then
uh black plays some combination of
knight f5 and h5
discouraging g4 if g4 right away i have
knight h4
so
i had this structure recently i think i
had this thing as nemo
this is kind of the quintessential
structure
from when you play a6 on move two this
is kind of what i'm dreaming of
and the play kind of flows very nicely
there's no bishop e3 because the knight
controls if king h1 i might have
kind of fantasizing about h4 probably
not yet though
bishops better align with these things
but sometimes if this diagonal opens
there is this like crazy
h4 knight g3 idea
uh she probably wants to play
wait how to make this work
for this move whoa the fish
the fish 27 96 gifting 10 subs
thank you the fish really appreciate
that
who just subbed himself
also thank you abc zach welcome back
this move wait a minute
seems close to like crushing but
calculating this this this takes takes
doesn't quite work
i want to make it work
i shouldn't be spending so much time
here maybe queen
let's try this
not sure after d4
so this this or this and then this is
something to keep in mind
wow
oh the position's so pleasant i just
want to savor it
i'm thinking d4 here
it kind of closes things down
maybe i could play a4
like white's really stuck i shouldn't
have been spending so much time
oh it takes takes yeah let's take
queen's tie down to the knight
so now the diagonal's open which i can
reposition the bishop
i don't care about that pawn i just care
about mating the king now
it's kind of annoying have this move
queen might get stuck
i've learned so much watching your
streams and youtube uploads
oh good to hear the amazing work
let's go okay let's not flag the scheme
i'm unpinning the night so i can
attack everything all the content
learned a lot from your channel
oh that's so nice to hear yeah thanks
for all the positive kind words
makes me happy let's play this move now
hitting the queen hitting the bishop i
still want to play this move
knights are not connected i know i know
i know
queen has to move back i think
oh there's cool idea okay so queen a4
expected
i mean what else to do for white
oh wait a minute i have a few cool ideas
but queen a4 is looking at h4 g4 and
then h
wait either h3 or knight g3
and takes takes knight h3 rook h392 made
in the end
is this force main i think it's force
mate so takes takes knight h3 only legal
move takes king g192 mates
oh it's such a beautiful mate
this let's go that was such a nice
finish
i was kind of dreaming of this like back
when i mean back when i got this setup
it's kind of one of the main ideas and
it came to life
okay so that will probably go on youtube
sorry irene irene has to be such a
victim hi youtube
of uh of this masterpiece
[Music]
but shout out to irene who's also
streaming
uh she's been me many times in also
beautiful fashion
um so if this goes on youtube i'll link
her stream and her youtube channel
in the video description ready to shave
your head only 996
7757 subs to go
oh on twitch okay
yeah uh
i'm ready i'll have to invest in maybe a
better razor or scissors
no razor might be hard to shave with
with scissors
okay uh youtube people say hi to twitch
chat
twitch chat has been being so happy
and also saying hi to youtube i
connected all the level 5 emotes nice
yeah hi youtube
and oh thank you megatron 54
subbing with prime oh yeah if you have
amazon prime you can subscribe for free
it supports the channel
i do appreciate the prime subs